はぁぁ
私は先端医療の一種としても働いていますけれども一人の位置としてまた一人の人間と
して思っているのは優れた医療は芸術であり優れた芸術は医療であるとそういうふうに
私は思っています
そのことを今回皆さんと共有したいと思います芸術と言いましてもとてもまあ領域
が広いので今回はあえてですね古典芸能にで関してですね古典芸能といるような
つながりということを開いて取り上げてみたいと思いますみなさん古典芸能と言います
とどういうものを想像されるでしょうか
古典芸能といっぱいありますよね実際ですねまぁ日本にある芸能っていうのは例えば
芸道と言われるもの
茶道華道香道さ照度をですねそしてあったブドウと言われるもの
ぶどうの中にも例えば柔道があり県道がある旧道があり国道がいろんなものがあります
それ以外にも例えば演劇の中ではですね炎があり狂言があり
歌舞伎や人形浄瑠璃そういうものがありますし他に園芸
と言われるもの講談落語もしくは間合いを取るものですねあとは歌音楽のようなものは
彼であったり
雅楽であったりそういういろんなものがあります今回はですねその中で特にですね各々
能楽っていうものをですねちょっと特に取り上げてみたいと思います
これは私が今東京でノーちょっと稽古してるんだ
けれども私は熊本にまあ高校まで行ったんですけどその時はですねまったくを能なんて
知らずにですまた興味もまったくなかったんですね
んですけれどもまあ東京に行っていろんな機械があって真央のお稽古するようになって
実は熊本ってものすごくお能と関係が深いということはあとでもしていました
こちらですねまあ泉ジンジャーというですね水前寺公園の中にあるま薪能の様子です
これは今年の8月にまぁ実際自分が入って撮った写真なんですけれども
熊本にはですね能舞台が舞いつつありますひとつ目がこの水前寺公園の泉神社
二つ目は藤崎宮の能舞台また藤崎宮が元々あった場所にですね御旅所だにあまおう旅所
と言うとがありましてそこにも能舞台があります
そしてそれ以外も菊池神社
まあそういうものまあいろいろ熊本には能舞台が実はたくさんあるんですね
じゃあ熊本にじゃあそもそもを脳が入ってきたのはいつか
それはですね日東京正公がまあ能楽集を熊本に連れて来てからになります
まあ日東京正工程が熊本城作った方ですので
実はですね熊本城の
歴史は400年ぐらいの歴史とまぁ熊本でものが始まった歴史は400年
藤崎軍を毎年実は400年構い途上の懊悩しておりまして
こういう間はほとんどまないというぐらい熊本はとても脳に塩が縁深い土地と言われて
おります
で私がまあなぜそもそもをのまあ1子でありながら始めるようになったかというとです
ね
まあいろいろそれはまあきっかけがあったり興味深いところがあったんですけれども
a もう一つ目はですねまあお能の世界というのは
普通のスポーツとかと違ってですね50歳ぐらいだとまだ全然ダメなんですね
60歳70歳80歳90歳となるとより動きの質が深まっていくというそういうような
世界で
私は今からその高齢化社会を迎える上でですねこういう年を取れば取るほど動きの質が
深まるって動きはものすごいこれは何か a 調布
あの秘めてるんじゃないかとこれをもっと勉強したいと思ったんですね2つ目はですね
まぁ知っていうことに関しなんですけれども
色では必ずやっぱり人の子っていうものと向き合わざるを得ないんですけど
どもそういうことはなかなかですね医療の現場でまぁ学校の教科書でも教わることない
んですね
そのマイアの亡くなった方をどうやって弔うのか
そしてまた残された方の心のケアどうするのかそういうことをずっと自分なりに
いろいろ研究していた結果
実は日本の中の芸能の中の王脳というのはですね
車亡くなった方を主役にする芸能というもっと世界の中でももうこれ唯一しかないん
ですけれどもこういう特殊な芸能だということでそれで私はそこに興味もしました
で3つ目がありますってこの3つ目はですねこの世阿弥という人が1600年1400
年くらいんですねこの
there の斧をまとめてそれをですね風姿花伝というですね本にまとめてます
僕はこの本を読んだ時にですね本当にこう頭の先から足の先まで電撃が走るような
すごい衝撃を受けたんです
それが僕が一番まあいろんなのを始めるきっかけになっています
それはこういう一説になるんですけれども秘技
に曰くそもそも芸能とは書林の心を和らげて上下の顔なさん古都宿増長の基
カレーエイネカレーエネ法なるです日雨キワキワも極めてや書道ことごとく塾延長なら
んとなるって書いてあるんですねぼくはこの本読んだ時にすごく不衝撃を受けました
これはどういう意味かというとですねそもそも
芸能というものはみんなの心を和らげてウエアしたという考えから自由になって寿が服
を増やすものなんですよと
そして寿命を長くするものなんですよそしてこれを脳だけじゃなくてすべての道照度を
すべての道はこの寿命を延ばす
寿は服を増やすこういうことなんですよということをですねこの脳の奥義の日でー
演奏の中に書いてるんですね
僕はこれを読んだ瞬間にですねこれまさに医療そのものなんじゃないかというふうに
思いました
つまり本来医療の本質とは何かということを考えたときに上下のここ人の心や笑って
ですね上下の顔な山ほど医者患者と上とか下って構造から自由になって
寿と服を増やして元気に生きていくことだとそして寿命を延ばし
いく法則なんだとかこれがまさに実はいるようなそのものなんじゃないかと思ってそれ
で僕はすごく衝撃を受けてそれからの始めるようになりました
で僕はずーっとその医療の本質って何なんだろうということですねずっと臨床医として
働きながらずっとそのことを自分なりに探求し続けて色々考え続けてきたんですねその
中でバージャー日本の色の歴史はどうなんだと
日本はずーっとどういうふうに色の変遷があったのかということを調べてみようと思っ
てですね本読んで
教科書で勉強したんですねそうするとまぁ教科書に日本の医療の歴史
どういう風に書いてあるかっていうと538年ぐらいに仏教が中国から入ってきたとき
に
中国医学入ってきたそこからまあ日本のいろんな歴史始まりますよとそこからも始まっ
ているんですねその後ま蘭学オランダの乱獲が入ってきました同一医学入ってきました
アメリカの医学が入ってきましたそしてまあ今の日本の医学がありますまあそういう
ような説明になっているんですけれども僕は本当にそうなのかな
それだとずーっと日本のオリジナルなものではなくてずっと受け身でもらったもので
作られたとまあそういうふうな説明なってるんですけれども本当にそうなのかなって
ずっと僕は思ってたんですねその時にぼっこの前雨の一声
つに及んだ時にですねそれが僕の疑問がパッと氷が溶けるに氷解したんですけれども
これどういうことかというとですね医療の本当の本質っていうのはもちろん病気を治す
ということも大事です
でもそれ以上にですね心は何なのか体って何なのかいのちって何なのかその本質を本当
に深く知るということが子が本当が色の本質のところにあると思います
そういう意味でその昔の人達っていうのは心の知恵体の知恵
そういうものを医療に
したんじゃなくてそれをもっと高い次元に高めてのピットが芸術真央のに代表されて
ですねビットか芸術の世界高めていったと
だから医療という形では全然残ってないけれども別の形でカラーだとか心の知恵が全て
残ってるんじゃないかとまあそういうふうに僕は思ってそこでをノート医療というのが
繋がったんですね
じゃあそもそもじゃあそれはすごく突飛な考え方なのかというとですね実はそういう
ことはなくてですね
今私が病院に行って受ける医療っていうのはまあいわゆる西洋医学というものでこれは
正
既出社100年100年くらいの医学なりますですけれどももともといろんな国にです
ねその土地に根付いた伝統医学というのがありまして
伝統医学とその今の西洋医
学っていうものをいろいろ研究するとですねその本質は何かという風に僕の中で考えた
ところ
一番の本質はですね西洋医学っていうのは基本的に病気を定義するんですね
私は心臓の医者ですけれども例えば心臓病心筋梗塞とはこういうものだ
表親子はこういうものだ病気を定義しますそしてそれを何とかはい女子をなんとかそれ
を戦ってた遅
闘病という言葉もありますけれどもそういうふうにその病と闘ってそれをな
とか勝ちましょうとそういうのが西洋医学の基本的な発想になりますそれに対してです
ね伝統医学っていうのは何をするかと病を定義するんじゃなくてそれぞれの健康はどう
いうものか調和っていうものはどういう状態なのかそういうものを定義してそれは皆が
決めるものなんですけれどもそれに向けて時今自分ができることは何なのか
それをやっていくと
ですから基本的に私たちの体っていうのはある何か調和の場としてあるんだけれども
不具合が起きたときたそのバランスがこうちょっと崩れてしまったと
そのバランスが崩れたものなんとかまた元に戻すっていうことが大事であってそこに
あんまり病気っていう場合には必要ないですね
自分にとってじゃあ何が一番丁場で何が一番元気でいきいきとして
いるのかその向こう方向に向かってそれにおけるそでその方向に向かうために何かを
やっていくかそういうことをやっていくのがまあ伝統医学というものも考え方です
ですから西洋医学はですね自分の体を基本的に洗浄戦いの場としてみるわけですね常に
この身体の中で戦争が起きているとそういうふうに体を見ます
これに対して伝統医学っていうのは人間の体つのある長はの場であると
この身体の中にはですね皆さんあ私もそうですけど皆さんの体の中にもこの1つの体の
中に60兆個の細胞が全部生きてるわけですね
しかもその中に腸内細菌も入れると何百兆て腸内細菌がいますから
みんなの体の中にそのものすごい数の生命が生きてその多様性と長がの中で生命は生き
て
ん
その体のバランスが崩れたから対応性と調和の場に戻していきましょうという風に考え
ますから遠投医学はどっちかってですね体を戦争の場として捉えるなるでしょう元の場
として捉えるそういう違いがあります
そういうことで伝統医学っていう考え方はどっちかと伝統芸能そういうものと実は
かなり島性があるんじゃないかというふうに思ったんですね
またその最初優れたいるは芸術であり優れた芸術は医療であるというふうに話しました
けれども
色と芸術の設定に関してまた別の視点をちょっとご紹介したいと
ます私たちは生きている限りですねどんな人も赤ちゃんのときから
年取った時もですねずっと起きて寝て起きて寝て起きて寝てってこのサイクルずっと
延々と繰り返していくんですねそもそもこれがなんでこんなことが必要なのかで皆さん
なかなか考えることないと思うんですけれども
これが結構生命のシステム全体を保つためすごく大事なんです
ねつまり私たちは起きている時に目が外に向いて耳が開いて全部外を向いてずっと外を
向いて生きているわけですね
そこで社会やいろんな人との交流を行っていくわけです
ですけれどもそうするとどんどんの意識が外に向かって言ってですねこの自分の命とは
この内側にありますけれどもここからどんどん離れていっちゃうんですね
ですからまた
ほど自分の命それはまるで家に帰るように家に帰ってこないといけないわけです
このために私たちは強制的に眠るって時間があって自分たちの意識ができない無意識の
世界それは心臓とか内臓とかいろんな命の世界ですね
それに戻る必要があると
この2つの異なる世界外側の向かう1串
意識内側に向かう意識してこれは全く両極の世界なんですけれどもこの2つをぐっと
つなげる人があるんですねこれがまあ僕は芸術の世界なんじゃないかと思います
この大きているようで寝ているようなこの2つの意識の状態が重なった状態というのが
まさにゲー
技術が果たしてた世界なんじゃないかこのこの時間っていうのはですねまさに芸術の時
無我夢中という言葉がありますけど我をなくして夢の中この夢の中の状態で私の体は
リペアーというよりむしろリボンみたいなですね再生もう1回生き直すそういう体験
私たちはしてるんじゃないかとそういうふうに思います
さてば最初にですねお能の話が出ましたので
ぜひですね皆さんをノートちょっと関係性を持っていただきたいので皆さんでですね
ちょっと脳の一節をですねみんなで声を出してやりたいと思いますのでぜひ皆さん声を
出していただきたいと思います
この曲は誰かサボっていう曲なんですけれどもこの高砂という曲はですね熊本のですね
阿蘇神社の神主さんが
た
美容する話になりますので実はものすごく熊本とも縁が深い曲です
そしてこの高さ号っていうのはですね夫婦和合歌う曲で明治座今では結婚式で必ず
だあれしてきたものすごい
めでたい歌があります
まあ声をみなさんだしてくださいと言うとですねああ私音痴だからちょっと恥ずかしい
って思われるかもしれないんですけれども全く心配しないでください
この昔日本の歌の世界というのですね皆さんがいいって出したらですねこれが基準に
なりますですからそこから上か下かというもので全てが始まっていくのでその第一声目
これがすべての
非常になりますのでこれは全違うんですねその基準で皆さん
声を出していてください私がまあ1節1行ずついますので
そして歌ったらその後入っていますのでぜひ皆さん
声大きな声でです音一音一音はっきりと歌っていただきたいと思います
じゃあ行きます
いい
沼尾版人目のタービごろーんもん
はい
いい
goo
[音楽]
me
いい
赤から光栄だしてくださいね飯間
版人目の旅号よ御門
はいっ
me
アイエイアイ
4を
へーも行くううう
すぅ映像ひさー ce ちょっと難しいですけど
はい
姫もう給付
[音楽]
nao
そういい
次はセリフになりますそもそもこれは杞憂集肥後国
はい
そうこれは神
いい
阿蘇飲み屋の神主ともなりとは
は学校となりー
はい
4 ee ああああ
彼は
いう感じででも皆さんありがとうございました
これが高砂という曲になりますであのまあこれはですね皆さんこれ違うんですけれども
これは全員違っていいですねですけれどもこれが全員違う声はもう重なるとこの大旺盛
な声がそのまま調和して重なるということが
まあ日本のもともとのこの音の世界
ということになります
で私は最初ですねまぁ日本の今井諒は芸術であり優れた芸術は医療であるというふうに
話しましたけれども
今夏 oh no ですね特にま取り上げたわけですけれども
次これ奉納だけじゃなくてですね伝統芸能をすべてもしか芸術全般する音楽とか美術と
かですね
もしくは食そういうものにも僕は実は言えるんじゃないかとストレス
べて命に関わることで私たち1000人誰かがそれを何か切実な思いで生み出したもの
なんですね
ですけれどもその心っていうのはなかなか見えにくいのでなかなかそれはどういう思い
で作ったのかってなかなか分かりにくいですけれどもその思いにちゃんとですね
その声を耳を澄ますということが大事なんじゃないかというふうに思います
これはまあ熊本城なんですけれどもまあ自身でですね傷ついた熊本図を見てですね皆
さんもないか
胸額ギリギリていざんだりですね思わず涙をこぼされたら方もいるんじゃないかと思い
ますけれども私も東京で見てですね
本当にその思わず涙の流しました
えわたしたち人間っていうのはですね誰か自分以外の
ものものにもですね痛みを感じですね
痛みを感じるんですねそれはまあある意味思いやりだったらコンパッションと言われる
ものですけれどもこれはすごく大事なことです
ですけれども熊本の歴史っていうのは熊本城が400年の歴史がありますけれどもこの
下には熊本の心というのがあるんですねそれはたとえば伝統芸能だったりいろんな形の
分
文化としてあるもので私はそういうこともですね大事なんじゃないかというふうに思い
ます私たちはもう1回その加工というものをもう1回思い出してですね現在ともう一回
関係を不正を取り戻すとそれが未来につながることなんじゃないかというふうに思い
ます
伝統芸能とかまあ昔の体の使い方はですね
この平素まあさっき声出すときも並走丹田てのはすごく大事になるんですけれども
なんでここが大事かとおそらく僕が思うのはですねこのへそうっていうのはですねお
かあさんの命ともともとつながったんですね
お母様隊の人つながっているそれはずっとつながっていてこれは数百年生
風船ねぇ数十億年というレベルでこれは命がずっと繋がったわけです
このつながれた1回も途切れたことがないんですねしかもさが昔の何時を置く年と言う
歴史から見ると私たち今生きている人ってのは全員その歴史命の歴史の最先端にいる
わけです
ですから私たち生きているとだけですべてのそういう過去を背負って生きているわけ
ですから
私はもう
1回そういうふうに過去を再発見して現在と関係性を繋がそれが私たちは過去現在未来
というものが
ガシッと命がつながるということなんじゃないかというふうに思いますご静聴
皆さんありがとうございました
[拍手]